the former district attorney in the
ahmed aubry case has been indicted on
account of obstruction and a violation
of her oath i really didn't see this one
coming this all relates to ways that she
allegedly mishandled the case of ahmed
aubry who was pursued and gunned down
while jogging through the atlantis
suburb the former district attorney
actually recused herself early on
because one of the alleged gunmen was a
former government employee and charges
were only brought by the georgia
attorney general two months later after
cell phone footage of the shooting was
released to the public the indictment
says that former d.a johnson violated
her oath by not disclosing that she had
tried to appoint d.a barnhill to the
case after she recused herself when she
recommended that barnhill be appointed
by the attorney general and the
indictment also states that she
knowingly and directed two police
officers not to arrest the alleged
gunman which apparently gives rise to a
potential obstruction charge this is
absolutely wild and comes out of left
field so we'll see everyone in court